[Music]
when it comes to illusions optical
illusions get all the attention but the
whole body you have can be fooled and
can't fool the brain one of my favorite
physical illusions is the thermal grille
illusion and you can do it right at home
I have some hot dog halves in an ice
bath I also have warm hot dog halves now
what I'm going to do is marry the halves
together so that they alternate warm
cool warm cool when I'm done I will have
a torture device but not one that hurts
your body one that hurts your mind
[Music]
Rosanna pansino hello my god welcome to
minefield Rosanna pansino is the host of
the Youtube cooking show nerdy nummies
so I thought she would be the perfect
candidate to try out our hot dog
illusion now you didn't hear or see
anything I just did right no good
alright well you are in for a treat what
I want you to do is take the bottom of
your forearm and place it skim Joey Kay
right onto these hot dogs Oh would you
feel OH
but now touch them individually like
warm cold warm cold but none of them is
as hot as they all felt together so
what's going on show oh yeah what we've
built here is a version of the thermal
grill illusion and for reasons that are
still being debated this can cause a
sensation of pain maybe the sensors we
have specific to hot and cold are both
also specific to extreme pain and
getting them to fire right together
makes the body think whoa whoa whoa if
they're both firing that near to each
other that means get away Red Alert red
alert
that's aware yeah so what I'm really
trying to say is that this is a great
way to hurt someone without their ever
being a mark or any actual damage it's
pretty sneaky dude
try this at home
[Music]
the surface of the human body contains
millions of nerve endings that send
touch related sensory information to the
brain but in some cases those sensations
don't even need to be generated by nerve
endings ever heard of sympathy pain the
most well-known type of sympathy pain is
called couvade syndrome it's when a
pregnant woman's husband goes through
labor pains husbands can actually
sympathize with their pregnant wives so
much that they experience the same
problems such as weight gain insomnia
nausea mood swings etc sympathy pain is
also known as synesthetic pain its pain
sparked by seeing someone else get hurt
amputees can actually be more
susceptible to it because experiencing
trauma can make the brain more sensitive
to other people's pain amputees can also
feel pain in the limb that is no longer
there that is known as phantom pain but
perhaps the most surprising way that the
brain and pain interact can be
demonstrated by the nocebo effect have
you ever heard of the placebo effect
it's like when a fake pain pill actually
cures a person's pain because they have
a positive expectation it will work well
today we're demonstrating the exact
opposite if a subject expects they're
going to experience something unpleasant
like pain will they feel it even if it
actually exists only in their mind we've
told our subject that she's
participating in a study to test a
non-invasive bone-density scanner but
actually it's a totally fake machine
that we built from a desk lamp an air
compressor and the kind of $10 laser
pointer you might tease your cat with it
doesn't cause physical pain or for that
matter physical sensation of any kind it
doesn't hurt at all
you guys this doesn't work
but we'll the expectation alone make our
subject think she's feeling real pain so
come on in here just go ahead take a
seat right there and then when you feel
ready to drive just let us know and
we'll dismiss you okay thank you
first we have to make our subject expect
to experience pain and to do that our
actors are going to scare her a little
sorry Jessica this is for science so are
you already done yeah I just mean I'm
gonna let me get together what you do
it's like a targeted laser
test bone density did it hurt yeah by
the look on her face it appears we have
successfully primed our subject for
what's to come
the question is when put to the test
will she actually feel pain when there
is really none there this is Jessica hi
Jessica
did you have a seat everything in this
room the medical equipment the hospital
supplies even the demeanor of our fake
nurse is designed to play on Jessica's
mind to psychologically induce the
anticipation from pain we're testing out
some equipment it's not invasive we need
to measure the side effects and patient
reaction and I want you to be really
descriptive about what you're feeling
and pay close attention to the pain that
you feel and how it grows notice how we
are suggesting that she will feel pain
further raising her expectations I'm
gonna give you a ball to squeeze for
pain management okay
and anytime you want to stop stops right
away okay okay
[Music]
definitely warm like
like tingly after only about seven
seconds she's already feeling a physical
sensation on her skin where there is
none
keep in mind we tested our fake bone
scanner and the light emits zero heat or
feeling of any kind yeah no it doesn't
feel that great right off no it's okay
for 30 seconds it's really like stinging
the stings of sting and like really
really hot now it's hot we're at 45
seconds okay thanks you described warm
turning to hot it was like warm than
that like heat grew into more like a
sting on this pain scale did you point
to the amount of pain you were feeling
between us six and a seven according to
the pain assessment scale she
experienced significant pain if this is
completely up to you but we can move to
level two which is slightly more intense
how many more levels are there there's
just five there's five levels or five
but again you're in the driver's seat
yeah sure let's do it
here's another test of our nocebo will
she feel an increase in her level of
pain if she expects to are you ready
keep in mind level two is fake we're not
doing anything different than before
meaning nothing is happening to her yeah
started off higher than the last time I
say
definitely like already stinging
immediately she reports increased
painting on level two it's 15 second it
feels really really really hot and like
penetrating how do you thirty second I
don't know like half an inch or like an
inch got it is very hot like burning
[Music]
like my whole arm is like on fire
we can stop at any time yeah thank you
could you rink for me how you felt at
level two like nine and a half the power
of suggestion was so strong
our nocebo caused our subject to think
she felt almost the worst pain
imaginable other subjects felt different
imaginary sensations the muscles are
kind of kind of burning a little bit how
did that feel that was like a seven
actually it's tingling a lot more now
than it was before
I was surprised at the intense reaction
some subjects had to a feeling that was
created only in their minds we're gonna
stop it now that was 45 seconds describe
for me the sensations that you were
having it felt like a little prickle
like when you get goosebumps
what about our original subject who
experienced a severe nine-and-a-half
on the pain scale how will she feel when
she learns it was all in her head
I want to debrief you on everything that
we're up to today so this is a
psychology program and this equipment is
not doing anything to you this is just a
machine that makes noise and that's just
a laser pointer on a lamp for real for
real we're never in danger this is the
investigation in pain anticipation yeah
that worked
[Laughter]
you did say that you felt a prickled
uh-huh how do you feel about that
whether it was really I didn't get it
goosebumps or I was nervous which is why
I felt it I know as a person like if I
think there's gonna be pain I'm gonna
feel something I do still feel like kind
of like a burning sensation
my arm really yeah the power of
suggestion is so strong that this
subject continued to imagine a physical
sensation even after learning it wasn't
real the name for the effect is the
nocebo effect it's a negative effect
caused by nothing but the mind it makes
perfect sense you know the power of
suggestion I'm shaky just thinking about
it
[Music]
pain and touch are weird but what about
when touch straddles the line between
pleasure and pain when a sensation makes
you laugh and drives you crazy I'm
talking about tickling part of what
makes you laugh when you're tickled is
the element of surprise your brain
doesn't know exactly what to expect or
when it's going to happen on the other
hand it's impossible to tickle yourself
if the brain knows where and when and
how you are going to be touched you
won't laugh
but professors of cognitive neuroscience
at the University College London have
invented the tickle machine subjects it
in the tickle machine with their feet
against a brush that is connected to a
handle at first when the subjects turned
the handle the brush rotates at the
exact same time resulting in no tickling
then the machine is switched into tickle
mode which causes a delay of less than a
second between when the subject turns
the handle and when the brush moves
against their foot this is light change
is enough to prevent the brains
cerebellum from predicting the sensation
thus allowing the subject to respond to
the tickle tickles can be fun
pain not so much if you couldn't feel
pain that would be great right or would
it
let's meet Steve Pete Steve I understand
you don't feel pain yes I was born with
a rare genetic condition called
congenital insensitivity to pain only
affects about 40 or 50 of us around the
world with it only 40 or 50 people so
far that we've been able to find I'm
tell me what it means when you say you
don't feel pain pain is used to detect
injury that kind of sends a signal to
your brain saying hey don't do this
anymore it's an alarm system so what
happens with my condition is we feel
what's going on like if I were to touch
your shoulder you and feel me touching
your shoulder but if I were to touch
your shoulder in it in a way that's
painful I would feel just the pressure
and the signal of pain would not travel
to my brain okay so you feel everything
else that I feel but you just don't feel
pain
correct but that could be dangerous how
did you first find out you had this
condition well what happened was I was
teething and I chewed part of my tongue
off
so my parents quickly took me to my
pediatrician Wow are you ticklish
yes do you itch yes do you like massages
yes
do you take painkillers no what about a
headache no but what spicy peppers I
enjoy them yeah I mean I do since the
burning sensation but nothing painful
what about intestine pain like gasps
pain that's something I don't feel so
that kind of ties in though one of my
biggest fears was just having like
appendicitis or any other type of
internal damage that I just don't know
about until it's too late
is there an upside to this I'm sure that
people often I evilly hear that you
don't feel pain and they think oh man
well you should become a boxer
the only upside doing is uh being that I
have has so many injuries during my
childhood as I get older I won't feel a
pain that comes with it other than that
really I just try to live my life
normally as everyone else does I cannot
describe pain to you just like you can't
describe a color to someone who's blind
which is where I run into my problem
with with trying to describe what not
feeling pain is like wow all that well
Steve thank you very much this was
really really fascinating so not being
able to feel pain is actually a bad
thing but likewise the anticipation of
pain can be bad too just making someone
think that they might be tortured soon
could be a torture device the CIA and
Guantanamo Bay are known for using
psychological torture involving the
anticipation of pain against prisoners
in the war on terror the effects of this
type of torture can last a lifetime
so what's worse waiting for pain to
happen or the pain itself you might be
surprised we're basing our investigation
on an anticipation of pain experiment
conducted at the University College of
London which gave subjects two options
option one experience intense pain right
away or option two anticipate a lower
level of pain in intervals every few
minutes researchers found that the
psychological effects of dread can often
be worse than the pain itself we decided
to demonstrate this phenomenon by
setting up a fake research study we are
looking into the effects of electrical
stimulation on the body it's all
completely harmless but it can be
unpleasant so we'll show you the two
settings alright I want to show you
first what we call the light setting
okay you ready I guess oh and then
there's the high setting oh okay all
right
so again unpleasant definitely but
you're safe we call this the low voltage
or light shock okay ready and now we'll
show you the the high voltage or higher
shock agha
okay now it's time for our subjects to
make an important choice all right so
now you bet you know the two differences
you either can choose choice a which is
one high-voltage shock every ten seconds
for a minute we'll our subjects choose
the higher more painful shocks but get
it over with right away or choice B is
one low voltage shock every ten minutes
for one hour or will they choose the
lower shots but be forced to anticipate
the pain for ten minutes between shocks
for a solid hour either way you will be
here for an hour what's worse a higher
level of pain or having to wait and
anticipate the lower level of pain take
a look I think I'll do the shorter more
painful what okay now that they've made
their choices it's time to see how our
subjects experience these two options
the subject who chose to anticipate the
lower level of pain during the course of
an hour is seated in the low shock
administration room along with our
actors who are pretending to get shot no
papers were harmed in the making of
issue this subjects our long ordeal is
just beginning
but what about the subject who chose to
get it over with and take the more
painful shots right away we're starting
no
here's shocked number one okay yes the
shock is painful but it was her choice
so this is shock number two it's really
painful shock number three tap over
exactly it may hurt more but she's
getting it over with quickly shock
number four number five number six okay
you're done
meanwhile our other subject is only on
shot number one that's one shot down
five more to go while the pain level may
be large this subject has plenty of time
for the pain and its anticipation to
occupy his mind
[Music]
hey Jerome did you come with me oh okay
finally his hour is up tell me about why
you chose the lower voltage choice I
guess less pain yeah while you were
sitting there waiting for ten minutes to
elapse how did you feel ain't you it's
so quiet in there so basically you got
your thoughts but your thoughts is like
okay it's coming this anxiety may be the
reason why in the original study a full
70% of subjects opted to receive the
more painful shocks right away rather
than suffer through the mental torture
of anticipation why did you choose the
higher shock group just knowing that it
was over within a minute I think 10
seconds is easier to go along with and
anticipate what was coming next so it's
kind of like ripping a band-aid off I
guess you'd rather fast hard and fast
yeah yeah yeah
tickling may be annoying and pain may be
well painful but we crave touch hugging
feels amazing
hugging can actually decrease your risk
of catching the common cold and hugging
can lower blood pressure
hugging can also release oxytocin the so
called bonding hormone I guess what I'm
trying to say is stay in touch
[Music]